(Cello music)
(Music ends)
On the flight here,
I was reminded about my mom.
I'm a self-taught cellist,
I've never had a lesson.
I studied double bass, but I just
picked up the cello and started playing
because I love doing it.
But my mom was an inspiration to me.
I did not realize she was an inspiration,
because she got her music degree
through a mail-order course,
the US School of Music.
While raising two kids,
she received a lesson a week in the mail,
and practiced.
And at the end of a couple of years,
she put on a recital.
And I'll be 50 this month,
and it took me that long to realize
that she was that big of an inspiration.
I'm just going to keep --
yeah, thanks, mom.
(Applause)
She's also one of the most
extraordinary people I know,
beyond being a wonderful musician.
I want to play a little bit for mom
and your moms as well, actually.
(Cello music)
(Music ends)
You know, when you normally
hear a cello, you think of this.
(Plays Bach Cello Suite No.1)
We're not going to do that today.
(Laughter and applause)
(Drums)
(Cello)
Hey!
(Looped samples of onstage sounds)
(Cello music and looped samples)
(Music ends)
(Applause and cheers)